찹타고 임장. 오늘은 한남동을 가고
있습니다. 한남동은 진짜 요즘에 워낙
또 각강도 많이 [음악] 받고 있고
그리고 빌딩 투자하데 있어서도 저희가
한남동 건물을 중계하고 나면은 임대도
되게 잘 맞춰집니다. 저는 만약에
어디 투자할래 하면은 한남동은 항상
들어가 있던 거 같아요. 한남동은
투자 가치가 [음악] 저는 굉장히
많다라는 생각이 들고 우측에 보시면은
UN 빌리지가 있습니다. 거기
거주하시는 분들이 빌딩 산다 그러면
다 한남동에 사요. 실제로 등기를
[음악] 봐도 다 이제 한남동에
거주하고 있습니다. 그리고 여기
우측에 보면은 제니가 인대 들어온
거예요. 바로 딱 건너자마자 있어요.
우측에. 그 디자인 회사가 매입해
가지고 저렇게 건물을 올려서 그때
임대할 때는 월 임대료가 한 5천만
원 정도였거든요. 근데 아마 [음악]
뭐 예상권데 뭐 정확히 임대료는
모르겠지만 그 정도 선에 맞치지
않았을까 싶습니다. 그래서 여기가
인근의 뭐 역도 없고 좀 진입하기가
쉽지 않은 곳이긴 한데 4억으로
쓰기는 [음악] 되게 좋아요. 그래서
위에층에 뷰가 되게 좋습니다. 우리
차량 진입하기도 좋아서 쓰기에는
[음악] 너무 좋은 건물이지 않을까?
네. 그렇게 생각합니다. 그리고 여기
건화편에는 [음악] 개발 구역들이
있어요. 그 구역에 들어가지 않은
건물들도 있는데 거기 건물도 [음악]
저희가 최근에 중계했었는데 셀렉
업체가 통임대로 들어왔어요. 네.
그래서 임대료 수준도 거의 20만
원에 가까울 정도로 되게 높은
임대료에 [음악] 들어왔습니다.
우리가 얘기하는 한남동이 아니긴
하지만 임대료 수준이 굉장히 좀
높다라고 보시면 될 거 같아요. 지금
좌측에 보이는게 [음악] 한남
뉴타운입니다. 한남 3구역이 제일
빨리 진행돼 [음악] 가고 있고
그래서 뭐 순천한 병원 인근으로 여기
이제 개발되고 나면은 뭐 배우
세대들은 더 많아질 것 같고 이제
한남동 상권이라고 불리는 곳이 저기
한강진역이랑 그 이태현역 [음악]
사이 이제 꼼대가 손길 거기 이면에
그 한남동 카페거리를 많이 가거든요.
어 젊은 여성분들이나 외국인
관광객들이 그쪽으로 좀 많이 가는데
거기가 아닌데도 불구하고 임대가
그래도 좀 잘됩니다. 저희도 놀랄
정도로. 그리고 이쪽으로 올라가면
한남더일이 있고 여기 앞에는 그
한남초등학교 있는데 요쪽 이면에도
원래 다 주택가였거든요. [음악]
여기도 오피스가 좀 들어갑니다. 그
여기 그 유튜버분 그 임대
들어갔잖아요. [음악] 그 이사배님
여기 안쪽에 원래 완전
주택가였거든요. 근데 여기 안쪽까지도
들어갔습니다. 그다음에 여기 위에
이제 북한남이라고 [음악]
불리는 곳이 있어요. 그래서 북쪽에
끝에 있는 한남동 쪽도 있는데 거기도
원래는 다이 주택가였어요. 여기도
오피스 임대가 그래도 꽤 문의가
많습니다. 저희가 최근에 리모델링
진행했던 [음악] 건물도 임대 무늬가
꽤 오고 있어요. 여기죠. 이제
북한남쪽이라고
보시면 될 거 같아요. [음악] 저희
리모델링 했던 거 살짝 보고
가겠습니다. 원래 완전 주택가였는데
오피스들이 꽤 들어와 있습니다.
한남동이 고급 이미지가 좀 있잖아요.
그래서 뭐 오피스나 쇼룸이나 명품
셀렉하는 [음악]
그런 곳들도 이쪽으로 좀 많이 오고
있는 거 같아요. 리모델링 했던
거죠. 요것도 임대 무늬가 상당히
오고 있습니다. 다 이렇게
주택이었어. 이것처럼 빨간 벽돌
건물처럼. 여기도 보면 다 건물 올린
것들 많죠. 여기가 진짜 좀 많이
한적했는데 변했습니다. 개인적으로
요쪽 길 좋은 거 같아요. 이렇게
공원 끼고 있는 여기까지도 사람들이
찾아옵니다. 여기 여기랑 멀거든요.
네. 한강진용에서 [음악] 굉장히
먼데 여기까지도 오피스가 좀 잘
들어오고 있습니다. 이로 나가서
저희는 그 [음악] 꼼대가루 손기
제일 비싼 거리를 한번 좀가 볼
거예요. 이제 여기 한강진역부터
[음악] 이태역까지 이어지는 거리라고
보시면 될 거 같아요. 여기가 제일
명품 업체라든지 이런 기업들이 좀
많이 들어와 있고 [음악] 그런
기업들이 또 비싸게 임대료를 내고
들어와 있기 때문에 가격이 그래도
한남동에서 제일 높다라고 보시면 될
거 같아요. 그리고 [음악] 지금
이쪽은 괜찮은데 저쪽으로 좀 갈수록
고저가 있어요. 거기 보이는 건물
층수가 1층이 [음악] 아니라
3층입니다. 졸로 들어갈수록 건물이
더 낮아 보인다. 노출이 좀 덜
된다라고 [음악] 보시면 될 거
같아요. 그래서 여기 보면은 저
건물은 되게 잘 나와 있지만 지금
보면 되게 낮아 보이죠? 근데 이런게
다 5층, 6층짜리 건물이에요.
그러니까 뒤에 고저가 있어서. 그래서
일단 이면에 들어가 볼 거예요. 여기
카페 거리입니다. 그래서 여기 라인원
여기 뒤에 후문이 있어요. 그래서
여기 원래 이제 완전 이제
주택가였다가 요쪽까지 이제 상권이
발달되기 시작했습니다. 여기도 보시면
알겠지만 관광객들이 이렇게 지나다니고
있거든요. 한남동도 뭔가 관광 코스인
거 같아요. 여기도 완전 진짜 이렇게
빨간 벽돌밖에 [음악] 없었던 어
그런 거리였는데 요런 거를 딱
리모델링 해 가지고 여기 이면에도
거의 2억 막 이렇게 넘게 팔립니다.
저는 한남동에 가장 먼저 봐야 될
길은 이제 이쪽이에요. 꼼대가 손길
이면. 그거 꼼대가 손길은 사실
[음악] 금액대가 되게 클 수도
있어서 투자하기 쉽지 않지만 여기
임면도 가격이 많이 오르긴 했지만
[음악] 어 그래도 제가 항상
얘기하는게 차라리 용의 꼬리가 났다.
뱀의 머리보다. 그래서 같이 한남동
메인 상권이라고 불릴 만한 물론 이제
더 안쪽에 있겠지만 여기를 가장
추천하고 그리고 아까 보셨던 북한남
뭐 이런데도 저는 괜찮은 거 같아요.
유빌리지 뭐 근처라든지 아니면
숭천병원 근처라든지 [음악]
요쪽까지도 괜찮긴 하는데 일단
일차적으로는 전 여기가 제일 좋은 거
같습니다. 네. 그래서 차타고 임장
어 한남동 좀 돌아봤는데 어 저는
앞으로 한남동의 투자 가치는 더
좋아질 것이라고 예상을 합니다.
그래서 용상고에서 거래가 제일 많이
되는 곳이고 부자들이 제일 많이
거주하는 곳이기 때문에 받아줄 사람이
많다라는 거거든요. 그래서 어
한남동도 굉장히 좀 유심히 투자하실
때 보시면 좋을 것 같아요. 네.
그래서 오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요.
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다.